the girag an experience unbelievable
how long to the mic this how he can work
dead foot how do you feel about your
son's impression of you it's really good
he doesn't think it sounds like him at
all he doesn't it's a you know something
well here I only know it because this is
how he talks to me all the time he'll
just be like mmm JB know what you would
you what are you doing today you got
work mmm you go sit back and talk to all
them people you'd be perfect for ASMR
and we should just make that type of
stuff yes like him him just breathing at
the airport coming from I think I was in
st. Louis or something like that and so
I'm behind his lady anybody Lambeth two
three people in front of her and I'm
behind her so I'm back then we make him
a little noise she was like oh oh Latino
woman Spanish woman and she looked back
and she went back back to looking for
with ninfea she said you make a lot of
noise you make a lot of noise sir
remember making any noise that's you do
when you got in the car today you got in
the car you
[Applause]
it's noises and the noises and questions
those are his those are his like the
moment you get in the car 90 you see
what happen how far we got go to get to
Joe we add mmm we're driving 30 miles an
hour he's like think you're going go
fast don't you think quick on it on the
freeway I'm like worth more on the
freeway it's 60 mile I'm going slow
right now but no his what his voice is
just like one of many I've come across
today could I do voice over and all that
stuff so it's one of those things where
I'm lucky enough to have that one in my
back pocket because sometimes I'll throw
it out there people that be like I don't
know a lot of people do it John
Witherspoon presents interesting that's
it yeah we practice on it
yeah man with it it's got to be nice
though seeing him get into show business
getting the stand up I came from
Lemke's so I hope you'll be successful
I'm gonna try my best to be successful
he's too busy counting his coins -
you're on your own good luck Pete but I
mean he's you know he's supportive but
he's one of those guys were cuz I didn't
want to do entertainment at all when I
was younger I wanted I wanted to do art
and when I was drawing I used to go to
college and then I didn't have to turn
art into a career so one of my friends
like why don't you try act and you're
always wasting time in class making us
laugh and I was like honest interesting
idea so I started like doing commercial
acts and won that but uh I have friends
who are comics like I don't usually
bring up he's my dad like it's something
that just randomly happens usually like
and when that comes across they're like
honest crazy so you got like a well of
information in the sense of being a good
comic and writing and this and that
not that I don't but it's just asking
him questions about stuff like that is
the funniest stuff cuz he's just been
like like he just said it's very flat
out and just kind of like yeah yeah they
do
be funny how much more can you tell a
guy though really yeah just yeah you
just got to get your own you know people
ask me do you go to the clubs and
hmmm right I featured for him and he
doesn't watch my set like I just go up
and I do my I do my time and I come into
the cream room I'm like are you ready to
go and he's like oh yeah did he uh they
sounded like they were laughing so sound
like you did pointers or anything huh
you ever give him any pointers a tips
better be funny I'm the one on the
opposite spectrum giving him tips about
like how he can how he can leverage like
his you know his notoriety in this day
and age on the internet that's my thing
ah so it's one of those things where
like if I have a question about stand up
I'll ask but he doesn't you know yeah
you should definitely have a very active
social media yeah we can help him right
so see you good yeah
who's on me all the time here's the
thing literally creating his social
media was just a fluke cuz one day like
five or six or seven years ago someone
trended that he passed away and because
of that we had to create social media
for him so when that happened he's
calling me and I'm getting calls from
random people who know him and also my
cousin's like I got family call me
crying like oh okay here's everything
okay and he called me he's like JD you
gotta help me uh some some wrong on the
internet they he's saying all my
family's calling me so we created him a
Twitter that day and then through
Twitter I told him I'm like well just
tell people you're around and we tweeted
out like hey y'all this is the real John
Witherspoon blah blah blah don't listen
to those phonies making up them rumors
because it was it was worldwide trending
or whatever like hashtag r.i.p pops or
something and then off of that as
twitter gained like 25k and i'm like an
hour and then later on down the road he
got into instagram kind of randomly
where he just uh he had an instagram
didn't really post and then I think one
you did you did just a random thing
where he was around yeah I talked to I
talked to Megan and and what's the name
in oh he was me he was making like a
joke about like bills cosby and whatnot
and he was like being a mess around with
him that does stuff bill and whatever
but other social media platforms
randomly found it reposted it and now
he's like he went from like 6k to like
120 ya understand social media but well
let's try to cram in a loop
[Applause]